So NAT is not a super great solution
to the shortage of addresses in IPv4.
It's a workaround.
But the real solution
has already been built.
And the world is kind of in
the middle of deploying it.
That solution is IPv6.
IPv6 is the successor to IPv4.
We're going from 4 directly to 6 because
protocol version 5 was an experiment
that didn't work out.
IPv6 fixes the address shortage problem
by having much longer addresses,
128 bits or 16 octets long.
That's 4 times as long
as an IPv4 address.
2 to the 128th power is really
a colossally huge number of addresses.
Billions and billions of times
bigger than the v4 address space.
In fact, the smallest block of addresses
that can be assigned to an end user.
Like a home in v6,
is a /64 network which is much larger
than the whole v4 address space.
But that means that IPv6
addresses are kind of long.
Like for instance here's
one of Google's addresses.
Now fortunately, the conventional
way of writing these 6 addresses,
let's a skip writing these zeros here.
Okay, that's better, a little.
Anyway, you might notice that these
don't look much like the four addresses.
They're written in hex digits
instead of in decimal.
In blocks of 2 bytes separated
by colons instead of dots.
But remember this is just
the human readable format.
The network actually sends these
addresses as strings of 128 bits.
Just like v4,
we designate the size of a network block
with a decimal number of
bits in the network prefix.
Google has all of 2607.f8b0/32.
And many other V6 locks as well.
Remember on IPv4,
a /32 means a single address.
Whereas on IPv6, it's a large
network with 96 bits of subnet and
host address in it.
So the world doesn't need nat with V6.
There's enough addresses for every
device to get a unique public address.
And IPv6 adoption started out very
slow but it's been growing strong for
several years.
Between mid 2012 and the end of 2015,
Google's measurement of V6 traffic
they received increased from about
half a percent of all traffic
to about 10% of all traffic.
And it's higher on weekends
because more home and
mobile users have V6 than business and
office users.